head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
here's a tweet from pop crave
pop crave's got 1.1 million followers
and they said Twitter suspends Ethan
Klein despite him following Elon musk's
stated guideline for Perry accounts that
is a lie that is absolutely not true
across the board all of these different
websites are lying about why uh these
people why Kathy Griffin and Ethan Klein
are being banned this is what I'm saying
I'm I'm I'm not NPR lied about that I
was listening report this morning on
that Ethan Klein banned after mocking
Elon Musk over verification Fiasco they
were banned because they changed their
images and names to Elon Musk without
putting parity in their name now here's
what pisses me off Elon gave them
special rules
why
so Milo got his verification removed
because he put BuzzFeed news reporter in
his profile malianopoulos and then he
was complaining about like why was
everyone's like well you put BuzzFeed
reporter they said you're not verified
then
the rules on Twitter are that you cannot
be verified and be parody
that's just always been that way Elon
decided to make special rules to allow
the left to do this so they could make
fun of him and they intentionally broke
the rules now maybe 40 chess he said I'm
gonna get him I'm gonna give them what
they ask for and they'll still reject it
he gave him warnings they rejected it so
these people don't want to be on the
platform they don't want to have their
accounts restored
these are these are these are people who
are engaged in outright
twit social media arson and the media is
lying on their behalf well they are yeah
there is there is definite lying going
on about this NPR was saying that people
were banned for having parity accounts
which was exactly untrue as well and uh
yeah do you think that musk just thought
that these people have him over a barrel
or something I mean he should clearly
not think that now that the platform is
growing so much but he knew that he's
he's got all the data he knows the he
knows the growth is happening and he's
he clearly doesn't care he's tweeting at
people eight dollars eight dollars of
the new learn to code right yeah he's
been doing that good man you know
there's that uh that that Viral Carl
popper I mean you ever see it where he's
like the little comic book and he's like
if you tolerate intolerance that
intolerance takes over
it's like okay
for you I will apply those standards but
for nobody else so if these people like
Ethan want to say it is good that people
are banned I'll say that when you're
banned so be it congratulations it's
what you asked for this is also a
difference in ideology towards the world
in general right so some people believe
in firm boundaries and Order and some
people believe in not feeding reactive
energy right and it's just two different
paradigms of approaching the same
problem and I've seen both things work
I've seen it to where if you put a firm
boundary it actually helps things and if
you don't have a boundary things go to
chaos but I've also seen it to where if
you forgive somebody and you say Hey you
know maybe get them to come around you
know maybe Ethan could come around like
like where where do you get to the point
that somebody see this even comes around
you don't but this is the problem with
this is that the dude has been involved
in so many high-profile cancellations
and advocated for so much yeah that when
you come into the conversation late
you're like maybe we can turn them
around it's like bro excuse me he's made
videos about me I never minded it but
the point is is that you know I can see
the gray area to any human being and
he's a very intelligent person and his
buddy Hassan's intelligent person
they're also very angry people I
disagree with most of what they say but
there their minds are sharp so they
might be able to see things a different
way it'd be amazing if you guys could
have more conversations see you're
filling in for Ian very very well here
so we've had this conversation way too
many times especially with Ian because
it's like no matter how many times an
evil person does something evil and
refuses an olive branch you know Ian is
always he's a good-hearted guy he's
always just like we got to give him a
chance and I'm like at a certain point
dude what would it take to get you guys
into the conversation you mean when I
invite them on the show consistently all
the time in good faith well they're
they're better and they use that to gain
followers and make up fake drama to make
it seem like I pulled some BS dude the
moment you tweeted them something nice
they use it for for views and they make
drama it's just out of the question I
think be an amazing conversation like do
you ever make it to L.A or they could
make it out here oh come on come on bro
like we've invited this guy on so many
times
I've invited Ethan I think once or twice
outright ignored Hassan actually agreed
and then privately dm'd and said I I
won't do it I'm sorry and I'm like okay
my son's got a lot of Courage I mean he
debated uh outright said he will never
do it really I'm surprised by that I'm
I'm not like is it because they want you
to go to Los Angeles no it's because if
you go to L.A they're going to decline
dude oh wow I can't keep having this
conversation okay like we have invited
all of these people consistently and and
what they do invariably is you send an
email where you're like we'd love to
have you on the show and if it's common
polite it's typically ignored sometimes
they'll then screenshot it post it and
be like they invited me but then started
calling me a racial slur it's just like
right the moment you open up
communication they're like now's my
chance to get views now's my chance to
make drama ooh they want to talk to me
let's make drama out of it yeah there's
no point well that's been a lot of this
whole Twitter thing is making drama
that's all it is you know it's like or
all the people who are saying that
they're leaving the platform and they
make giant big shows about leaving the
platform it reminds me of like several
years ago when people would leave
Facebook they'd be like I can't be on
Facebook anymore I just can't handle it
anymore and then it'd be like two weeks
later and they're just like hi I'm back
on Facebook it's like you gave me a
whole song and dance about how you were
leaving now you're back to a loser Elon
shut it give them warnings they defied
those warnings and intentionally got
banned and then started doing a PR run
of Elon Musk is is targeting me and they
don't believe in free speech that's why
I'm like no quarter because I believed
in free speech for these people over and
over and over again and every time I did
they turned it around as a PR stunt and
I'm like okay at a certain point you
have to recognize evil people are lying
to you that's it stop helping evil
people that's it help good people who in
good faith are censored when someone
comes out and says I if someone came out
and said I don't believe in free speech
and then got censored I'd be like okay
that person shouldn't have been censored
if someone comes out actively trying to
get people banned celebrating their
Bannings and says no one should ever be
allowed back on I'd be like okay well
that happens to you I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna defend you that's it
yeah there you go well I wasn't going to
go out there advocating for people but
I'd be happy to have everybody back on
the platform
um at this point it's like like yeah you
want to hear what they have to say yeah
why not like just have everybody on
Twitter whenever people are censored
they usually Double Down they're usually
forced into more kind of extremist
corners on the internet and they usually
never have even a pathway towards seeing
any kind of other semblance in any other
side of the story I don't know I might
be too optimistic but I think at the end
of the day bring everyone back this
whole debate let's have a conversation
and let the best ideas beat out the bad
ideas and I think that's gonna happen
and I think that's the strategy here and
and right and no one disagrees with that
and we got a good super chant the Super
Chat that makes a great example a great
analogy
a battle is being fought but but between
two ideological opponents one side
continually insists if we have The High
Ground we must seed to the lower ground
in an evil battle even Battlefield with
our enemies it's only fair and the right
thing to do and they say thank you and
then they start shooting at you again
yeah so it's like dude take that
I'm done with this
want free
research and have disparate opinions and
and angry opinions and bad opinions and
leftist opinions I don't care if Elon
Musk ban someone literally because they
were making fun of him I'd be like that
is BS but these are people who are lying
the media is lying they're claiming they
were banned for making fun of Elon Musk
total lies
they're saying they filed the rules
total lies they are setting fire to the
system and hoping we give them an
opportunity to come back I'm not doing
it anyway Whoopi Goldberg and what's her
name Gigi Hadid delete their Twitter
accounts
it's like a supermodel yes I don't care
these people are all leaving and Twitter
is growing more than it's ever grown
more and more people want to be on the
platform Elon Musk is making it funny
exciting and entertaining again and
these people are just like well I'm
leaving good so be it I don't care bye
so that this is the point Kathy Griffin
and Ethan Klein wanted to get banned
like along with all these other actors
they're intentionally leaving the
platform because you think that their
follower accounts are fake no I think
for a lot of them it's true like a lot
of high-profile celebrities you ever
notice they'll tweet and get like five
retweets they'll get like they have a
million followers and nobody nobody ever
interactions could I speak on that by
the way I live in Los Angeles I live um
right in the epicenter of this so I'll
meet the people they actually approach
me and offer to me to boost uh my
followers I say no because I think it'll
mess up your engagement but
um they'll point out to me all the
people who they've actually boosted
their followers it's apparent was very
very common for a long long time oh
really to have people like come in fake
followers fake engagement they'll even
get it to the point where they increase
the followers that increase the views on
the videos increase the likes increase
the comments and you can tell the
comments are very dumb and kind of
simple
um this is a huge huge thing they do it
because they're trying to get Social
proof
um some they do yeah well that's what
celebrities do just to make yourself
look more popular more relevant that's
what celebrities do now what politicians
do is even double later later later than
that because they're using tax dollars
for Bots and sock puppet accounts in
order to of course Galvanize political
stances and ideas that they want you to
believe that other people are behind as
well so this happens right big major
level this is where Elon Musk is smart
in 2011 there were Revelations leaked
leaked Communications showed the US
government was purchasing sock puppet
accounts to manipulate public opinion
they claimed not in the United States
nonetheless Twitter was heavily involved
so Elon probably looked at this and said
the intelligence agencies really want
these accounts they want to manipulate
they have no choice but to pay me eight
bucks per account they use so he says
eight bucks
now it's funny because all these
leftists are like there's only 400 000
verified uh individuals anyway even if
Elon Musk charged them all eight dollars
he wouldn't make enough to run the
platform and it's just like are you
stupid yeah he wants to charge people
who are not verified to become verified
so that he gets millions of Eight dollar
subscriptions but more importantly the
US government will now have to spend
eight dollars per bot and they probably
operate billions of them so elon's like
hey but here's the worst part that's my
money that's your money yeah yeah Elon
what each government taking our money
and giving it to Elon Musk well yeah I
mean that's that's pretty much his
history when you look at all the
businesses he started number one but but
you know as we talked about celebrities
having social proof the government I
think their proof is called like MK
Ultra proof or something but but they do
this on such a grand level and we are
literally at the precipice where all of
this could be exposed all of the
manipulation all the finagling all the
things that are happening behind the
scenes that we don't know about when it
comes to the big government putting
their hand up your you know what in in
your business that could all end with
Elon Musk saying okay I'm going to make
a stand here fake accounts fake Bots not
allowed here which is going to really
change the internet landscape as as of
course social media has become so
curated the algorithms are so controlled
that it's only what special interests
want you to see when we have free speech
when we don't have Bots we have the
first potential for actual real
conversations to happen that could
change not only the social landscape but
the political landscape of this country
and change it for what I believe to be
for the better since good ideas will be
able to battle battle uh bad ideas and I
think this has been happening on such a
big level especially during the last
three years especially during covet all
the bad ideas that that were followed
that people were going along with could
never be tested and challenged now the
government's going to face a reality
that they can't lie to us anymore and
that's going to be a game changer I
think they're going to keep lying to us
anyway but not on social media
if you guys have seen the article by
Darren Beatty from revolver.news about
Elon on musk and Twitter have you guys
seen those Darren Beatty on
revolver.news he wrote this one um these
incredible articles about how for Elon
Musk to buy Twitter is not like buying
Home Depot so even if Home Depot is
theoretically bigger Twitter is this you
know entire National conversation so
it's Elon is probably going to get take
so many hits based on this and there's
so many vulnerabilities that Elon has so
it's going to be tough for him I think
to make this truly free speech I think
it's I think it's still up in the air if
he's able to do this I think it's I
think it really is funny when you think
about the government sock puppets that
you know elon's businesses are all about
subsidy SpaceX government contracts what
what a test like they got subsidies or
what yeah especially when it comes to
carbon credits that they also sell on
the market right now that's one of the
ways that they still make a lot of their
money people don't understand that Elon
Musk is also for carbon tax also for
world government and uh you know
promotes a lot of the bigger globalist
issues as well the real dispute is that
the people complaining about Elon are
actually government sock puppets being
like we don't want to spend the eight
dollars as they buy us Tesla that's
right yeah
do you think like there have been a lot
of incidences where Biden has uh touted
EVs and stuff and he never mentions
Tesla yeah well now there's a big there
there was a big shift as of course he's
even promoting and giving tax incentives
to companies that don't produce cars in
the United States Tesla produces cars
exactly thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time